et ce soir le plus bel hommage qu'on
pouvait le faire c'était bien sûr s'il y
en a les yeux qui sera le meilleur bidal
ce soir on a trois candidats se sont
habillées maquillées coiffées comme toi
tour à tour et vont venir faire une
petite prestation on démarre avec bilal
morini bosc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toutes mes excuses
à
[Applaudissements]
nos jeux
je suis en droit rangera de je suis en
droit
[Musique]
la partie brune est apparue vers nation
non mais non je trouve qu'il est un
parti pris ya quelque chose j'aime bien
aller l'as bien la classe ya la classe
de bilal la classe de vidal ses
compliments sur pas sûr qu'on la
retrouve là le prochain
c'est bilal verdez en calme calme
[Musique]
bonjour
eve je suis
roy quand j'aurai je suis un poids
[Musique]
mais là il ira dans un instant il a
pensé de gilles verdez tu nous diras une
idée et enfin on termine avec
l'agitateur jean bilal
c
je suis en droit
[Musique]
non jamais
je suis en
[Musique]
ou même
[Applaudissements]
jean-pascal on voit qu'il a fait la star
ac à l'hôpital qu'est-ce que à ce qu'on
peut les mettre s'il vous plaît comme
nom moi j'aimerais qu'on les mette les
trois et que tu nous dis ce que tu as
pensé des 3 allée chez elle alors je
commence par qui tu commences par rabat
par isabelle alors isabelle s'était déjà
j'adore la tenue c'est la tenue de la
finale
les pèlerins des destinations eurovision
et c'est très très bien exécuté la
perruque et bien coiffée maintenant pour
la performance j'ai pas tout compris
mais je pensais que c'est ça qui a rendu
un moment magique
alors gilles verdez la tenue je la
connais gilles je les portais dans le
nord pendant un concert est très bien
exécuté la perruque un tout petit peu
mois la performance les les sauts de
kangourou
moi je sais pas j'ai pas ça mais il ya
quelque chose
l'équipe nationale alors jean pascal la
tenue c'est ma préférée clairement
détroit la perruque aussi j'aime
beaucoup jean pascal et on voit on voit
le talent d'artistes on voit l'agitateur
alors bilal tu vas faire un showcase
prochainement si maintenant choisir un
alors honnêtement j'ai un showcase dans
un endroit très spécial prochaine wyeth
et pourrait pour cette raison j'aimerais
choisir isabelle pourquoi il est au
chaud alors attendez à monsieur retrouvé
et il est où le showcase à le showcase
il est ou alors il est où le showcase au
salon du chocolat
[Applaudissements]
c